understanding the sentiment and meaning
behind language requires an architecture
that can handle a lot of data join us as
we talk to my toe AI about how they
handle their data processing on this
episode of stack chat thank you so much
for joining us today
can you tell us a little bit more about
my toe AI and what you do yeah so we
help large corporations increase sales
by finding insights and sales triggers
about their existing customers and
potential prospects and we do this by
analyzing large amounts of unstructured
data on the Internet
so what's the technology behind how you
make your AI we need to do a lot of
things with all this information the
first thing is you know detecting or
separating apple from Apple people think
that's trivial but it's actually quite
hard and we do it in a language agnostic
manner which means that through our data
processing pipeline we can process any
language and being able to do this for
all all very difficult cases not just
Apple and Apple but similar ones in
Norwegian and Swedish and German and
that's also what makes our technology
unique this combination of having a
language agnostic knowledge graph and on
top of that one building a lot of
machine learning modules to solve all
these really hard questions and we are
using Apache spark as our main data
processing platform which Patrick can
talk more in detail about so once the
spark streaming application has pulled
all this content from pub/sub it
processes it through our our NLP
pipeline this is where we do the entered
the extraction we cluster the content
and we interact with all these machine
learning models that we have trained
these models they are trained in Apache
spark as well in a batch processing unit
which runs on ephemeral clusters with a
pre empty nose which is awesome because
then we can just spin up a thousand
nodes and we can train really expensive
model for a short time and not have to
leave them leave them running and once
we have done that the last step in the
stream processing pipeline is to index
the data back into the knowledge graph
and for that we're using elasticsearch
which is also a really awesome piece of
software
got a really great searching
capabilities so you can search for
apples and get hits for Apple and that
sort of thing and once the data is
indexed into a lasting search it is made
searchable from our API which running
rough kill this API is run in a micro
service architecture in cubanía test so
that is kind of the ecosystem that
interacts with all the data that is
processed in Apache spark we make this
API accessible to our customers because
that's how they integrate mostly with
our service taking data from us and into
their internal CRM on prospecting
systems and we've even open sourced a
programming language in order to
customize api's in graphic UL very
easily so people should check that out
if they want to do that so obviously
over the last couple of years you've
learned a ton about your architecture if
you could go back and start again what
would you take with you that you felt
was the most important thing one sec
over here is that we are using a pasha
spark quite heavily and that means that
you have to configure a pasha spark
clusters and if I were to get in a
dollar for every hour every hour has 10
configuring spark lustres I would be a
rich man configuring spark cluster is
not not something that should be
underestimated you need to configure the
topology you need to configure how many
nodes you should have and all that all
that sort of things what you do get from
spark though is all of these machine
learning libraries and a lot of
utilities in this ecosystem but we could
have utilize those in a way by using
other kinds of systems either in Python
or or likewise so one obvious thing that
we perhaps should have considered more
is utilizing managed services like data
flow where you can use this managed
service that can do all the
transformations and then it can use
external API to do the machine learning
stuff and then you would also decouple
the system and have the data processing
one in one place and machine learning
can contain in other services so when we
started off we had a single messaging
queue where we published all of the
content this meant that if either that
queue one turn or some other service
interacting with a queue went down we
were clogging the queue
we would have a backlog over a lot of
things that would have to be processed
and that wasn't sustainable at least not
when a customer is they required that
the delay through our system is as slow
as possible so as a solution to that we
swapped over to pub/sub and created this
priority concept where you using machine
learning can determine which priority
queue should this content be put on and
that is that is based on feedback from
our customers either directly to our API
where the customers can choose what is
relevant and what is not relevant and
based on this we can infer what content
matters the most to our customers and
based on that we can utilize this to
route the content through the right cues
such that for instance a stock market
update is fit on the high priority queue
because we know that our customers would
want that as soon as possible thank you
so much for joining us today thank you
for having yeah thanks for having us get
started with data flow using these
templates and tutorials thanks for
watching and make sure to subscribe for
more great Google cloud platform content
we'll see you next time on stack chat
[Music]
you